i've had situations where i go to a
party and i notice
like there's a there's a chance there
might be a couple comedy fans and
they'll want to talk to me and that
actually makes me feel
less anxious like out and it does happen
like somebody comes up and wants to talk
about comedy and i'm like okay i can do
this and then i've had the opposite
experience where you're going and you're
like this is the worst i hate this i i
that was actually i don't have a lot of
pre-planned questions for you but i i
was curious
how do you find
being a public person like do you enjoy
it letterman style that's a good
question i mean it is
no because the first thing i thought
when you said that about the party i was
i was going to say like i have the exact
opposite reaction which i just don't
i i i'm i do like
parties the idea of parties and i like
i'm i am a social person but i always
like
parties i like the idea of parties i do
of people getting and the idea of fun
and it's fun and people are letting
loose and having a good time and music
and
um
you are can i just interrupt i'm sorry
we're so similar i have a bit i do on
stage where i go i went to my first
party after the quarantine and it sounds
so fun the word itself is fun party it's
a party and then you get there and you
realize you're just improvising
conversations just yelling where are you
from and and
and one more i'm sorry i'm talking too
much but gary schandling said to
seinfeld he said when will i be
comfortable at a party and seinfeld said
gary when you're comfortable at a party
you'll you won't be funny anymore so i
just want you to feel in good company
you were saying that's exactly what a
party is though it's like going up to
strangers and like having to start fresh
and yeah and
a lot of the time you know it is a lot
of time if you are a recognizable person
and you're going to a party in new york
or l.a you know the chances are people
know who i am
uh it's you know i don't know it's like
a little bit of luck of the draw i but i
do like it when it works out you know
what i mean yeah like well that's
somebody who i like and we get into a
conversation and it's fun but there's
that thing of like okay what you know
okay we're gonna here we go you know i
always feel that my wife would go to a
part like here we go let's you know
figure it out
and i i was saying this to elizabeth
before you came on the call i was like
you see this is what draws me to you
actually not just as an actor but as a
person is you seem
sort of
you're not like a juiced up
hollywood you're not like surfing on the
wave of stiller-ness
like just like rocking it out and when i
watched you
look i'm not this is not shot fired but
when i watch you on howard stern i was
so i was like uncomfortable for you
because howard howard's a pro
provocateur you know he's like he's like
why why you do greenberg greenberg no
money what you do that for no money and
like you haven't even sat down yet but
you you haven't sat down and he's like i
don't understand he'd united the museum
i understood that's a franchise that's a
franchise why but then you you do a
movie like greenbrick what's the cash
for that what's the cash and like
robin's also trying to ask you what the
cash is and i'm just like you
in a very human way i mean this is a
compliment
you're not slick you're not like what
howard you know one one for me one for
them you know what i'm saying like you
seem like a regular guy i tried to be
that guy no no the one for me one for
them didn't work out for me i i've tried
no i like the idea that that's an old
but i feel like howard it's gotten much
better with howard he's he's a friend
that was an old interview yeah but he
like you know his thing is i mean i
literally heard him talk like his thing
is he'll talk about movies like i want
to see good looking people don't show me
ugly you know another word for a
character actor is ugly person you know
that's his thing he just likes to yeah
you know relate to people on that level
which is great but it's but i yes i
definitely had that feeling of like
yeah you know how am i gonna explain my
you know my career or my life to anybody
and you know i don't feel comfortable
yeah i'm not like a guy who just sort of
like embraces the like this is my life
and let's live it to the fullest every
moment right right yet i do feel that
inside i feel that you know like an
appreciation
of my life and being alive and you know
all the things that i have in my life
and relationships and and uh being able
to live
in a way that's really comfortable like
so really i'm very you know aware of
that but i'm also not the guy who's like
hey you know let's make the most of this
moment right now what do you want to do
when i meet somebody
or that gets adrenalized and juiced up
at the mention of your career and just
like ah like just kind of jackson
pollock's all these bright colors you
you seem
you reminded me i admire people who do
that though i admire people who can just
live without any sort of sense of like
uh you know
self-criticism within what they are and
can be comfortable in their own skin
like that i actually think that's a
great thing
[Music]